Fünf Tage, 200 km, bis -20 °C.
Mit dem Husky-Gespann
quer durch die Wildnis Lapplands.
Vier Frauen und ein Mann
erfüllen sich ihren Traum.
* Energische, mystische Musik *
Doch aller Anfang ist schwer.
(Armin) Sie hatten Streit.
Im Armins Gespann
kommt es zu einer Auseinandersetzung.
Der junge Hund Cooper ist verletzt
und muss in die Box.
Danach beginnt der Genuss der Tour.
* Jauchzer *
Beim Abendessen redet Juho Klartext.
Effizienter werden,
nicht herumtrödeln.
Die klaren Worte zeigen Wirkung.
Die Schweizer
haben ihr Gespann nun im Griff.
Erschöpft kommt die Gruppe am Abend
auf dem höchsten Punkt der Tour an.
* Jauchzer *
Jetzt klappt's.
Doch Silvia hat Schmerzen im Knie.
Tut das weh?
- Oh, ja, ja.
6 Uhr morgens:
Tagwacht auf dem Alistunturri.
Chess, die 11-jährige Hündin, durfte
bei der Gruppe im Zelt übernachten.
Ja, es ist Schnee, kein Regen.
- Nicht wahr?
Das Schöne ist, dass man sich
am Morgen nicht kämmen muss.
Man zieht einfach
die Mütze wieder an.
Ich bin ziemlich
nach links gerutscht. - Ja.
Sag ihr bitte,
sie soll mehr nach rechts.
Du kannst nicht alles haben.
- Pfüdi!
Ja, also ...
Heute liegt die längste Tour
vor ihnen: über 50 km.
Dazu eine schwierige Abfahrt.
Packen!
- (Armin) Wo hast du deine Jacke?
Die Strecke ist selbst
für erfahrene Musher schwierig.
Juho sorgt sich um Silvia -
wegen ihrer Parkinson-Erkrankung
und dem verletzten Knie.
Wie geht es dir? Sei ehrlich.
Ich habe besser geschlafen.
Mir war warm genug.
Ich glaube, das schaffe ich heute.
Du und die Hunde
müssen einfach sicher runterkommen.
Kein Grund, etwas zu riskieren.
Du sagst es mir einfach,
du bist direkt hinter mir.
Sag mir,
wenn du eine Pause brauchst.
Wir versuchen, den Tag zu geniessen,
und müssen uns nicht beeilen.
Gestern ist ...
Da bin ich an meine Grenze gekommen.
An die Grenze des Möglichen.
Aber heute sind es 50 km,
und ich kenne den Weg,
weil wir den gleichen Weg
zurückgehen,
und das gibt mir Sicherheit.
Downhill ist noch etwas schwierig.
Das sagte auch Martina.
Aber wir ziehen es durch
und denken nicht daran.
Let's go!
Wir schauen nach dem Mittagessen,
wie es ihr geht.
Es darf nicht so weit kommen,
dass sie die Hunde
nicht mehr kontrollieren kann.
Wenn sie auf ein Schneemobil
oder auf ein Auto umsteigen muss,
werden wir einfach
ihr Gespann aufteilen.
Aber schauen wir mal, wie es kommt.
Das ist jedenfalls eine Möglichkeit.
Vielleicht machen wir auch einfach
nur längere Pausen.
Es wäre schön, wenn wir als Gruppe
gemeinsam am Ziel ankämen.
* Verspielte, perlende Musik *
Here is the box.
Im Team gibt es eine, die sich
auf die lange Abfahrt richtig freut:
die ehemalige Bobfahrerin Michelle.
Das ist gut. Mir gefällt das.
Schnell, aber trotzdem sicher.
Die Sicherheit der Hunde
steht im Vordergrund.
Es ist wichtig,
dass den Hunden nichts passiert.
(Flüsternd) Nicht wahr? Ja.
Ja.
Du und dein Team
habt die ganze Arbeit gemacht.
Anny, Schätzeli, aufstehen!
Wir sind parat.
* Bellen *
Ja, das ist fies.
Martina dagegen
hatte gestern Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe sehr gut geschlafen.
Wir hatten einen Hund im Zelt,
vielleicht war das der Grund.
Ich konnte auch durchschlafen.
Ich habe wieder Energie getankt.
Es geht mir gut, und ich bin
gespannt, wie es mir am Abend geht.
Die Beine spüre ich.
Ich habe Muskelkater.
Aber das war mir klar,
denn ich wusste, dass man
nicht einfach draufstehen kann.
Es ist wirklich ein Sport.
Ihr seid so süss.
Kann man euch mitnehmen?
Dich würde ich sofort
ins Gepäck nehmen.
Alle machen sich bereit
für die Abfahrt.
Barbara stimmt sich auf ihre Art ein.
Wollen wir nochmals jodeln, Leute?
- Ja, du!
Vielleicht machen die Hunde mit.
* Barbara jodelt. *
* Armin jauchzt. *
Wie sie alle geschaut haben.
* Bellen *
* Barbara jodelt weiter,
die Hunde bellen. *
Armin sorgt sich
um die Pfoten seiner Hunde.
Am Anfang hatte ich Angst,
dass ich zu fest ...
Jetzt ziehe ich sie fest an,
und wenn sie rennen,
fliegen sie trotzdem weg.
Man muss einfach schauen,
dass man alle Grössen hat.
So, Chess, komm!
Hey, ich muss dir
diese Pantoffeln anziehen.
Sie ist ein richtiges Weibchen.
Ich hatte auch eines. Es ist
das Beste, das man haben kann.
Hier haben wir
das verwöhnte Tierchen.
Ein echter Leader,
sie ist elf Jahre alt.
Die geniesst das richtig.
Und jetzt? Passt es?
Hm? Es ist gut, ja.
Silvia,
das ist deine Sicherheitsbremse.
Eine Kette,
die unter den Kufen durchgeht.
Ah, ja.
- So bremst es die ganze Zeit.
Auch wenn du
von der Bremsplatte abrutschst,
geht dir der Schlitten nicht ab.
Das hilft viel bei der Abfahrt.
Thank you.
Entspann dich, dehne
deine Muskeln ein bisschen. - Yes.
Das ist eine kleine Hilfe,
damit auf der langen Abfahrt
weder der Gruppe noch den Hunden
etwas passiert.
Come on! Come on, guy!
Wenn der Fuss von der Bremse rutscht
oder sie sogar runterfallen
und die Kontrolle
über den Schlitten verlieren,
dann wirken diese Ketten unter
den Kufen wie eine starke Bremse,
und der Schlitten wird nicht
in die Hunde hineinprallen.
So spielt es keine Rolle,
ob sie runterfallen.
Diese Ketten hier braucht es,
damit niemandem etwas passiert.
* Treibende, abenteuerliche Musik *
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
2 km Abfahrt, 200 Höhemeter,
steil und kurvig -
durch Bäume und zwischen
verschneiten Felsen hindurch.
* Unverständliche Anweisungen
von Juho *
Eine Abfahrt, die auch
zu einem Langstreckenrennen gehört,
dem Lappland Quest, das Juho
mit seinen Hunden bestreitet.
* Jauchzer *
* Treibende, mystische Musik *
Den Schlitten zu kontrollieren,
ist harte Arbeit.
Wie Profis kommen die Abenteurer
alle unten an.
* Jauchzer *
* Jubel *
Das war eine verrückte Abfahrt.
Ich hab's geschafft!
Der Rest des Tages fühlt sich jetzt
wie ein Spaziergang an.
Die Bremsketten halfen.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Vielen Dank für deine Tipps -
bezüglich der Gewichtsverlagerung.
Ja, du bist nicht runtergefallen.
Das war kein einfacher Hügel,
auch ich spüre ihn.
Wenn man will, kann man alles tun -
auch mit einer Krankheit.
Ich bin stolz.
Viele andere können das auch.
Man muss sich trauen und Mut haben.
Ich glaube, ich hatte hier Mut.
Es war super.
* Hecheln *
Für mich hätte es ruhig
etwas schneller sein können.
Aber es ist wichtig,
dass auch die Hunde sicher sind.
Am Anfang ... Die sind so geladen.
Die wären davon, und wir hätten
keine Chance gehabt, sie zu halten.
Ich finde es super, dass Juho
diese Ketten rangemacht hat,
die zusätzlich gebremst haben.
Es war sehr gut.
* Jaulen *
Er sagte vorher,
das habe er noch nie gemacht.
Und er hat mich umarmt.
Ein Finne
zeigt solche Emotionen sonst nicht.
Aber er ist ziemlich stolz auf das,
was er mit uns gemacht hat.
Bis ein Finne aus sich rauskommt,
braucht es was.
Es war wirklich sehr schön.
Es hat gepasst.
Ich erinnere mich noch:
Letztes Jahr,
beim Lapland-Quest-Rennen,
haben sogar die Profis
nachher gesagt,
dieser Hügel hätte sie geschlaucht.
Und die haben jahrelange Erfahrung.
Zehn Punkte für alle hier.
Yes.
Schön! Geniess den Rest des Tages.
Gut gemacht.
Definitely.
* Bellen *
Es braucht Mut, seine Komfortzone
zu verlassen und etwas zu machen ...
... das einen vorwärtsbringt.
Und wenn man es in einem
solchen Team wie hier machen kann,
das gibt mir sehr viel.
Es ist wahnsinnig.
Ich werde ewig daran denken.
Es ist sehr schön und emotional.
Aber ... ich freue mich so,
dass ich dabei sein darf.
Es ist wirklich eine Husky-Tour
des Lebens - wortwörtlich.
* Unverständliche Anweisungen *
Das schwierigste Stück ist geschafft.
* Mystische Musik *
Erst vier Tage sind
seit dem Start der Tour vergangen,
und aus Anfängern
sind fast richtige Musher geworden.
* Mystische Musik *
* Unverständliche Anweisungen *
Sie verschmelzen mit ihren Hunden
zu einem Team.
Sie spüren, wie Ruhe und Weite
ihre Herzen füllen -
mit der Freude,
die sie gesucht haben.
Yeah!
Ride in!
Vor dem verschneiten See nochmals
ein Augenblick zum Geniessen.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen,
mystische Musik *
* Spannende Klänge *
Die Strecke an diesem Tag
ist noch lang.
Aber der Anfangsstress ist gewichen.
Ich bin gedankenfrei,
grüble nicht an irgendetwas rum,
was ich sonst häufig mache.
Es ist ein Moment des Abschaltens.
Wir sind gerade auf einem See.
Nur schon die Vorstellung,
dass wir auf einem See fahren,
ist irrsinnig schön.
Es ist einfach eine Weite ...
... in der man sich
sehr klein fühlt.
Die Natur ist so wunderschön, da
muss man gar nicht so viel denken.
Einfach nur dankbar sein für das,
was man hier erleben kann.
Die Route
führt über den gleichen Weg,
den sie gestern zurückgelegt haben.
Die Hunde kennen ihn.
* Energische Musik *
Nach zwei Fahrtstunden
ein Stoppsignal von Tourguide Juho.
Davon hatte er der Gruppe
nichts verraten.
Ich passe auf die Hunde auf.
Ich mache das schon.
Legt mir
die Snacks für die Hunde raus.
Ich habe keine mehr.
Sie hat noch.
Die Leute
von der Gemeinde Pasmajärvi
haben von unserem Abenteuer erfahren
und haben
eine kleine Überraschung bereit.
Ich schaue zu den Hunden
und schicke die Gruppe hinüber
zur alten Mühle.
Ich habe so eine Ahnung,
dass sie da etwas Leckeres erwartet.
Pasmajärvi ist eine kleine Gemeinde
mitten in den Wäldern Lapplands
mit 31 Einwohnern, verteilt
auf 8,3 km2 - am gleichnamigen See.
Umso grösser der Stolz darüber,
den Schweizern ihre Sehenswürdigkeit,
die alte Mühle, zu zeigen,
wo sie Essen und Musik
vorbereitet haben.
So schön, mega.
So schön!
* Jubel *
Wir haben nur
etwas Kleines für euch.
Nur etwas Symbolisches.
Danke vielmals.
* Fröhliche Akkordeonmusik *
Barbara bittet Armin zum Tanz.
Ich bin kaputt.
- Jöö.
Vielen Dank.
- So schön.
Mit diesem Schuhwerk.
- Man kommt kaum vom Fleck.
Ihr habt das elegant gemacht.
- Hay, ay, ay.
Die Leute aus Pasmajärvi haben
stundenlang lokalen Lachs geräuchert.
Die Gruppe erlebt die traditionelle
finnische Gastfreundschaft.
Wow!
Es ist alles nass.
- Das macht nichts.
Is it okay, if we put ...
Ich möchte gerne mal zwei Monate
lang in so einer Hütte leben.
Zwei Monate hier draussen ...
- Lädst du uns auch ein?
Ja, nacheinander.
Michelle, du wärst die Erste.
Ich nehme das Grösste.
Reich beschenkt.
- Genau.
Zum Wohl.
(Alle) Ooole!
(Armin) Das ist heiss.
- Ein solch intensiver Geschmack.
Der Hecht ist auch irrsinnig.
- Der Geschmack ist unglaublich.
Die Familie vermisst man,
aber nicht stark.
Man hat gar nie Zeit,
daran zu denken.
Das stimmt.
Ich muss ehrlich sein:
Das geniesse ich jetzt für mich.
Am Abend denke ich kurz daran,
und das wissen sie auch.
Meine Frau weiss ganz genau,
dass ich das geniesse.
Es ist nicht entscheidend, ob sie
etwas von mir hört oder nicht.
Sie hat Freude,
wenn sie etwas hört - wenn man kann.
Aber wir haben ja kein Handy.
Also auf das Bett
freue ich mich schon.
Diese Schneehügel ...
Mit der Zeit, wenn sie
am Rücken oder an der Hüfte drücken
und der Schnee gefroren ist ...
Ich freue mich mehr
auf den Komfort eines Bettes,
aber sonst vermisse ich nichts.
Ich hätte nichts
gegen ein etwas komfortableres WC.
Nur schon eine Holzkonstruktion.
Damit man die Oberschenkelmuskeln
nicht so anspannen muss,
dass man umplumpst,
wenn man nicht mehr kann.
Denn dann hat man ein Problem.
Auf Wiedersehen. Wir müssen weiter.
Danke schön. Tschau.
Vielen Dank. Das war für uns
eine sehr schöne Überraschung.
So kind. Thank you.
Um 14 Uhr liegen noch über 30 km
in der Dunkelheit vor ihnen.
* Dramatische Trommelmusik *
Silvia, die befürchtet hat,
nicht mehr mitzuhalten,
ist immer noch dabei.
Die Temperaturen liegen bei -15 °C.
* Dramatische Trommelmusik *
Mit über 15 km/h ziehen die Hunde
die Gruppe durch den Wald.
Für sie gibt es kein Halten mehr.
Dann ein Schreckmoment.
* Finnischer Ausruf *
Beim Überqueren einer Strasse
werden die Hunde in der Dunkelheit
fast von einem Bagger überrollt.
Alles ist noch einmal gut gegangen.
Und Armin bekommt an diesem Tag
noch einmal die geballte Kraft
seines Hundegespanns zu spüren.
Armin ging der Schlitten ab.
Jetzt konnte ich die Hunde
festhalten. Es geht wieder.
Meine Lampe fiel zu Boden.
Ich mache so und ...
Okay.
Umgekehrt.
* Bellen *
So sieht es besser aus.
Du hörst nur leise den Schnee,
der unter den Kufen knirscht
und die Hunde, die rennen.
Sie kennen den Weg. Mit ihnen
kann einem nichts passieren.
Als ob man
durch die Nacht fliegen würde.
Das ist ganz cool.
Auch die Wirkung in der Nacht.
Das ist cool.
Manchmal bin ich froh,
wenn ich die Piste nicht sehe.
Es geht einfacher,
wenn ich sie nicht sehe.
Jetzt haben wir
den verrücktesten Hügel vor uns.
Vorher war auch ein Anstieg,
bei dem ich
für ein paar Minuten festsass
und den Schlitten rausziehen musste.
Aber dieser Hügel
ist wirklich steil.
Wir machen oben sicher eine Pause.
Dann kommen wieder die Ketten ran,
um zu bremsen.
Und wir fahren runter zur Hütte.
* Dynamische Musik *
Seit über 6 Std. unterwegs.
Vor ihnen liegt der letzte
grosse Aufstieg der Tour.
* Anfeuerungsrufe von Juho *
Die Schlitten
sind beladen mit bis zu 40 kg.
Nur gemeinsam schaffen Mensch
und Hund diese Herausforderung.
* Dynamische Musik *
* Barbara juchzt. *
(Barbara) Super.
Bravo. Sackstark!
Sackstark.
* Winseln *
Oben angekommen.
Silvia ist stolz.
Sie hat mit ihrem Arzt gewettet,
dass sie ihre Parkinsonsymptome
auf der Tour weniger spürt.
Ich habe ein Tagebuch geführt.
Und ich habe mich beobachtet.
Wenn ich etwas Schönes
für mich mache,
würde das die Symptome verringern.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Ich kann natürlich
nicht immer machen, was mir gefällt.
Aber wenn ich Sachen mache,
die mich glücklich machen -
auch wenn es noch so streng ist -,
sind die Symptome nur halb so stark
wie bei Leuten,
die nichts machen,
zu Hause über sich nachdenken
und sich fragen, warum es
ausgerechnet sie erwischt hat.
Das bringt überhaupt nichts.
Weitermachen. Weitermachen.
So.
(Juho) Noch eine Abfahrt.
(Barbara) Ich wünsche mir,
dass dieser Traum nie aufhört.
(Juho) Ich finde es okay,
dass das der letzte Anstieg war.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Aber mir gefällt einfach alles.
Nein, kaputt bin ich gar nicht.
Eher etwas enttäuscht,
als wir oben waren. Es ist so schön.
Ich geniesse es,
diese Zeit zu haben.
Zeit, um zu träumen
und Lebensvisionen zu konstruieren.
Ich habe alle Aufgaben vergessen.
Das ist verrückt.
Das gibt es sonst kaum.
Das ist krass.
Wenn ich nach Hause komme
und überlege, was alles kommt ...
Aber in diesen Tagen
habe ich nie daran gedacht.
Das habe ich noch nie
so krass erlebt.
Wie eine Art Schnitt.
Jetzt bin ich hier in dieser Welt.
Es könnte mir
nichts Besseres passieren.
Es ist etwas vom Besten, was ich
bisher in meinem Leben gemacht habe.
Es ist schwer zu beschreiben.
Alles ist perfekt.
Es tut mir so gut.
Das ist genau das,
was ich gebraucht habe.
Und ich liebe wirklich alles daran.
Ich bin von Herzen dankbar.
Was wirst du am meisten vermissen?
Das Zeitlose.
Wir sind vier bis fünf Tage
in der Natur draussen.
Es spielt keine Rolle.
Ich weiss nicht, wie spät es ist.
Wir gehen mit der Natur.
Zu Hause lebe ich getaktet -
mit allen Pflichten, die man hat.
Diese fünf Tage
waren für mich Freiheit.
Das ist prägend.
Ich werde bestimmt sehr oft an
diese Momente und Tage zurückdenken.
Und ich werde versuchen,
die Qualität der Ruhe
und der Stille mitzunehmen.
Dieses Im-Moment-Sein.
Ich wünsche mir, dass ich das
in meinen Alltag mitnehmen kann.
Dass ich den Moment geniessen
und im Jetzt leben kann
und nicht schon an 1'000 Sachen
voraus und an Termine denke.
Und diese Freude,
die auch die Hunde haben.
Wenn sie rennen,
bedeutet das alles für sie.
Sie leben im Moment und geben alles.
Und dann sind sie zufrieden.
Nicht wahr?
* Ruhige Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Die Tage alleine mit den Hunden
in der Wildnis Lapplands
neigen sich langsam dem Ende zu.
* Treibende Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Gegen 19 Uhr erreichen sie
ihren letzten Rastplatz am See.
* Befehlsrufe von Juho *
Stopp. Ho!
Alle haben es durchgestanden -
die Hunde und die Abenteurerinnen.
Das hat sie schon
ziemlich herausgefordert.
Das war sicher am Limit.
Und selbst für mich
war es nicht einfach.
Sie mussten bestimmt
raus aus ihrer Komfortzone.
Ja, ich glaube, das stimmt.
Zum letzten Mal versorgen sie
ihre Hunde für die Nacht.
Entschuldigung. Jetzt muss ich das
nochmals wechseln, Schatz.
Es hat super geklappt, nicht wahr?
Jetzt bin ich extrem zufrieden.
Eine ganz tiefe Zufriedenheit.
Ich glaube,
ich habe etwas von ihnen gelernt:
dass man gegenseitig
vollstes Vertrauen haben muss.
Egal, ob Mensch oder Tier,
in jeder Beziehung.
Es ist eine Beziehung,
die du mit diesen Hunden hast.
Vertrauen ist wichtig.
Ich bewundere sie.
Sie haben so viel Energie.
Und diese Faszination.
Sie sind so begeistert.
Ihnen ist es egal, wie schwer
du bist und wie viel Gepäck du hast.
Die machen einfach. Geradeaus.
Genial.
Ich habe mich definitiv verliebt.
Das kann man so sagen.
Ich möchte nicht an morgen denken.
Ich habe heute kurz daran gedacht.
Das war nicht schön.
Das war emotional.
* Schniefen *
* Schluchzen *
Es ist verrückt,
innerhalb von vier Tagen
so eine Bindung erleben zu können,
so eine Liebe zu bekommen
und zu geben.
Aber wie so häufig: Alles Schöne
hat irgendwann ein Ende.
Aber noch nicht heute.
Ich staune einfach,
wie viel mir so ein Tier geben kann,
wo ein Mensch Worte finden muss.
* Gefühlvolle, melancholische Musik *
* Mystischer Gesang *
Ein letztes Mal aufstehen,
ein letztes Mal die Hunde einspannen,
die ihnen ans Herz gewachsen sind
und ihnen erst das unvergessliche
Erlebnis ermöglicht haben.
* Mystische Musik *
(Juho) Oi, oi, oi.
Juho hat Vertrauen
in junge Hunde gesetzt.
Etwa in die einjährige Mayday.
Und andere,
von denen er nicht wusste,
wie sie das Abenteuer meistern.
* Heulen *
Sie haben sich viel besser gehalten
als erwartet.
Gestern war verrückt.
Aber sie haben durchgehalten.
Oft können Hunde einen Tag lang
eine harte Strecke rennen.
Du siehst erst am nächsten Tag,
ob du übertrieben hast,
ob es zu schnell oder zu weit war.
Mayday hat alles gefressen -
am Morgen und am Abend.
Jetzt sieht sie aus,
als hätte sie gar nichts gemacht.
Das war die richtige Entscheidung
und auch das richtige Tempo.
Ich war überrascht, dass ich sie
nicht in die Kiste nehmen musste.
Das waren mehr als 50 km heute
und einige harte Aufstiege.
Es freut mich wirklich, dass meine
Hunde immer noch so gut drauf sind.
Mayday.
* Er spricht finnisch. *
Wärmen wir die Girls etwas auf.
Das ist die richtige Einstellung.
Was bedeuten dir deine Hunde?
To me?
Das werde ich viel gefragt.
Die Antwort
ist immer noch nicht einfach.
Es ist ein Mix aus einem Haustier
und einem Sportkollegen.
Wie in einem Sportteam.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
ich sei der Coach,
sie die Athleten oder die Kollegen.
Aber im Nachtlager
sind sie dann eher wie die Tiere,
für die ich sorge.
Es kommt darauf an.
Aber ich würde sie trotzdem nicht
einfach als Haustiere bezeichnen.
Mit denen macht man nicht
so was Verrücktes.
Man wirft ihnen auf dem Sofa
einen Ball zu.
Ich glaube,
eigentlich sind sie Teamkollegen.
Du schaffst es
durch keinen Sturm ohne sie
oder kommst diese Hügel nicht hoch.
Aber sie brauchen dich auch -
für das Essen. Du sorgst für sie.
Ready?
Jetzt könnt ihr euch
etwas entspannen.
* Gefühlvolle Musik *
Heute Morgen schon
hat es mir das Herz zusammengezogen
beim Gedanken,
dass wir uns
von ihnen verabschieden müssen.
Das geht einem nahe.
So schöne Tiere.
(Juho) Ready?
Yep.
* Sanfte Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Für eine kurze Zeit
aus den Verpflichtungen des Alltags
ausbrechen.
Fünf Menschen,
die sich nicht gekannt haben,
sind zu einem Team geworden.
* Epische Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Sie mussten lernen,
sie mussten sich überwinden,
sie mussten kämpfen.
Und sie haben alle etwas gewonnen.
Zeit.
Zeit, wieder einmal zu spüren,
wer sie sind und was sie wollen -
in der Weite und der Ruhe Lapplands.
* Sanfte Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Und so endet dieses Abenteuer dort,
wo es vor fünf Tagen begonnen hat:
auf der Ranch von Juho.
* Dynamische Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Mit fünf Menschen, die ihrem Leben
ein neues Kapitel hinzugefügt haben.
Jetzt könnt ihr ziehen.
Jetzt seid ihr zu Hause. Hey.
Und Fremde zu Freunden gemacht hat.
* Gefühlvolle Musik *
* Dynamische, tragende Musik *
Denn manchmal ist es an der Zeit, das
zu tun, wovon man immer geträumt hat.